well it's the season of giving and
entertaining and this year Shoppers are
prioritizing saving time and money as
they make plans to celebrate the
holidays according to a recent survey
more than 30 percent of consumers say
they will attend or host multiple
holiday Gatherings and we could all use
a little help to get ready we spoke with
one expert and basketball wife to learn
how she hosts without the stress
holiday hosting can be daunting but
there are some easy tips to follow for a
game-winning plate explains lifestyle
expert Danielle Musselman well what I
like to do is plan my parties and then
after that you want to have a few things
on hand in case you get invited to
something last minute or you have some
unexpected guests drop in so I always
keep pre-made appetizers in my
refrigerator so that they're always
there and ready to go these here are my
favorite the spinach artichoke bites
other options the cheese stuffed
mushrooms the shrimp flatbread is
amazing the easy thing about these is
that they all cook at the same
temperature seed as pop them in the oven
put them on your own serving dish and
then you look like you were slaving in
your kitchen for hours and Musselman
didn't forget about the star players the
members Mark ham is something even the
pickiest of eaters will like it's under
five dollars a pound and then I gotta
tell you about my husband's favorite the
prime rib it's under 13 a pound so also
a great value find more holiday treats
and deals at samsclub.com